[Music]
and
kind of sort of hometown
and a shockingly unemotional goodbye
i would have liked it to go a different
way but
it is what it is this is your the
bachelorette season 16 episodes 10 and
11 plus the men tell all recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zima
and we have got a lot to talk about
so i'm settling in have a seat
i'm very happy that you're here yes
everyone we have monday nights kind of
an episode also a men tell all you're
condescending
i don't see us being friends after this
and tuesday night's definitely an
episode with kind of hometown have you
had
a true new york slice no to cover
what did you guys think of these
episodes especially the mento all and
the shocking goodbye
on tuesday nights we're going to talk
about it but let me know in the comments
below
so you know i like to have a good
experience feel a good
vibe i'm getting comfortable
i know i had red wine last week and this
week but the thing is that the
bachelorette shouldn't normally be
airing at this time in fact no bachelor
franchise show should normally be airing
at this time in the dead of winter near
the holidays and you guys are like a red
wine in the winter it's a little cozy
and then and then
and then we have
[Music]
a charcuterie oh you know
i adore a charcoat again we got a lot to
discuss
so i might need a delicious snack i'm
even wearing loafers
yes
that's all i never wear a flat on the
show i wear a high heel but today
we got to be ready for anything so let's
get to it i know how serious you guys
are here too and it's like
the reason that i'm here is very very
very true so we are back
with blake yes blake is still here
i forgot blake was still here but forget
the familiar faces you forgot we've got
a new face
of course we've been missing the travel
but we've also been missing like the
little characters we get on dates
you know the people who work at a spa on
the spa date or uh
the monk when we go on a monastery date
but today we've got
this lady and i'm a reiki and crystal
master
so blake and taisha are gonna go on a
one-on-one and this woman's walking
towards them
she's shaking something did you ever
make a rainmaker in school when you were
a kid
like a tube with rice in it that's what
it kind of looks like
we know we could use some rain out there
in the desert maybe that's what she's
doing
she comes up to blake and tatia and
calls them
seekers seekers seekers
welcome thank you and while i'm sensing
that this woman is spiritual in some way
i will say that in my mind
there's only one seeker but you
not a seeker so i
am loving this and i want my energy
cleansed and i'm so excited to see what
she's going to do
and she gives blake a hammer to break a
rock
i want you to crack this open yeah
so a blake breaks the rock in half oh
god
and that's the energy of that rock oh
and um this woman says that as long as
tasha and blake each have
half of that rock they are connected
as long as you have this stone you will
always be connected
and if you've been wondering what are
tasha's feelings for blake
blake says i love that tasia says
cool hmm i like that huh
we know what's gonna happen on this
one-on-one right
so we're wondering if tasha's into blake
and
in true fashion of this season we are of
course getting
naked i would like to
ask you to please this rope
sorry naked-ish at least naked-ish
they're laying next to each other
they're doing tantric breathing
look inside the soul see
each other and when tasha is looking
into blake's eyes
she's not seeing much
i don't see it yeah don't drink every
time
tasha isn't into blake i don't see it
we haven't really progressed as much as
some of the other relationships
i'm still trying to figure this out i
don't think he's my guy
oh yeah and then she says that she is
definitely confirmed officially
not into blake it's time to go our
separate ways
oh but then as much as i forgot about
blake
and thought i didn't really care the
blake breakup
is breaking my heart
she is so apologetic
she is crying and i just don't like to
see our angel goddess mermaid human cry
don't drink for all tasha's tears
cried out of my mouth i'll still drink
it though i got it in the cup
i didn't see that coming at all oh blake
is gone and tasha goes to see the guys
and talks to them with tears in her eyes
because tasha's had a realization and
she knows who she wants in hometowns and
it is not
rightly all right
[Music]
goodbye lee and just like blake
this parting is more difficult than i
thought it would be
and i don't want to lead you on
riley's response was so hard to watch he
asks tasha
why did you keep me this long why keep
me around so long
he says it's painful to sit here and
look at you smile
the longer i look at you longer i hear
you talk
see you smile the more pain i feel
he is leaving feeling like tasia
is the one i felt like and i still feel
like tasha is the one for me
[Music]
and i'm happy to have met i don't regret
that at all oh
he even gave her a forehead kiss did
riley's goodbye make you fall in love
with him let me know in the comments
below
and at this point tasha is crying
more
crying to no one i'm sorry
she is apologizing to the night
sky oh cam i'm sorry
to the world to the galaxy
has this been the most heartbreaking 10
minutes in recent bachelorette history
let me know in the comments below but
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving and we've got to go on
heading into the rose ceremony things
are getting
really really serious so now brandon is
talking and
i also kind of forgot about brandon no
cheers to being exactly where we should
be
he had a great first one-on-one but
where has he been hun
that rose to me is yeah a big step
oh and now uh noah is talking and uh how
uh
is he still here how are you good to see
you guys look like you've seen a ghost
and then bennett is present and
accounted for
at the rose ceremony yes of course last
week we saw bennett return out of the
shadows into the night and dacia said
she didn't know what to do so he could
go to the rose ceremony but
you know what this is going to be
short-lived
[Music]
i will say i'm happy to see him because
he's wearing a full purple suit
that's a look i love a look i like when
the men sport a look on the show
something to discuss
oh antaisha is pretty in pink
that dress those sparkly shoes she is
our barbie glitter queen
and speaking of a good look chris
harrison is back
hey guys welcome back chris hello hey
yes he's returned after taking his son
to college and
zach and bennett sit right up when he
walks in as they should
[Music]
all right this is it the rose ceremony
for it's all-ish for hometowns and
ben already has a rose from his
one-on-one and now zach gets a rose
i cannot wait for you to be a family dan
ivan gets a rose dan brendan who we
forgot about gets a rose
[Music]
sorry take a moment say your goodbyes
it's a goodbye that should have happened
like three episodes ago right
what did you think of sending bennett
and noah home i said this before i
thought tasha should have just
said bye when they were on the two on
one but you know bennett's good
television and we needed him and
moore bennett says that he is confused
i'm feeling
hurt i'm feeling sad but
it's more confusion really as much as i
had kind of turned on our superman in
recent episodes
i don't blame him what did you think of
the way that bennett was brought back in
only to be sent back home it's more
confusion really
let me know in the comments below i hope
he's learned a little
and i think superman will fly again
hopefully on the beaches of paradise
you don't need no harvard to agree to be
in paris eat and breed with me
you want to go inside yeah that smells
fresh in here
i'm literally trying to love you up
[Music]
all right so zach says and i quote this
is all gas
and no breaks all gas no breaks here we
go
santa says and i quote this is all
bizarre in the best possible way
so bizarre in the best way possible
and that's this season for you am i
right
and speaking of weird now because our tv
schedule got all messed up because the
pandemic
in the middle of this episode it's the
men tell all
due to the times we're living in this
will be a much more intimate
men tell all and speaking of visuals
i am loving this set what did you guys
think
there are fewer men i would imagine in
part because of quarantining and testing
and the pandemic and all that
and so they got to sit on these like
velvety couches
and i've got a velvety couch like that i
adored that they were green
big fan bennett is of course in a scarf
and don't drink for every time he did
that old school sexy glasses thing
[Music]
i got anyway
i thought riley also looking very good
and kind of a fuchsia turtleneck
love a turtleneck ed not bad in an
eggplant
suit whose outfit did you like best let
me know
in the comments below for me it was
definitely not
kenny in camo coming from the one
direction party boy manager
wearing camo so we've gotta talk things
out and we go back into the bennett and
noah of it all
his insecurities i don't have any
control of him okay
um personally i think he's intimidated
he
has but can you say one specific example
where i said something that was
condescending to someone
i'm not gonna get into it because we've
so recently lived it
but ultimately who did you side with i
did land
back with bennett because even though i
turned on him even though he was kind of
condescending to noah
what it's all about is if you can own
for your actions
and apologize for them and then it did
that i'm sorry that my words
came across as you know condescending
noah
said this i personally think you're an
ostentatious
harvard d-bag try to build bridges babes
not burn them
[Music]
this is something that viewers did not
get a chance to see
but they deserve to see you're welcome
america we also have a little fun
and get some unseen footage from the
reiki master date
and this was a lot to uh
[Music]
take in forgive me
yeah i don't know how to word this
properly um apparently during
this one-on-one blake really got his
chakras
charged where are we gonna look at this
actual
oh there's a lot there but blake himself
says he's a very open
guy including with his sexuality i'm a
pretty like i guess like sexually open
guy like i think sex is a big part of
love and
passion and i appreciated that they
acknowledged this because
guys who have been on the shows have
done interviews in the past saying that
yeah there were times when they would
get
excited and not be able to hide it and
you know we've never
talked about it on the show and if this
season is anything
it's about being the most honest and raw
and real ever it's just funny that like
that came to light as much as it did
oh this is beautiful oh and speaking of
being charged up joseph is here
joseph wonder if he will build or burn
a bridge i expected way more from the
oldest bachelorette
yeah you know i didn't need to see this
guy again but i thought
maybe he wants a second chance maybe he
is looking for a moment of redemption
baby he
wants to atone and own no no no no
sif no i have no regrets
yeah the way riley was looking at joseph
uh his face said it all but what did
joseph
have to say uh did he have any regrets
for the way
he spoke to claire believe getting that
you're not
fit to be a mother to my child does he
want to apologize
no i have no regrets i mean the thing is
i mean everything i said was factually
accurate i don't
know sif
you guys everyone was shocked i couldn't
believe this
chris harrison even said and i quote i
rarely do this i rarely do this
i want to try to help you help yourself
and my heart was racing
what was he about to say and he told
joseph
broseph you are wrong
that was really not a good look it just
the way the weight escalated the way you
spoke
he told him to apologize he asked a
question that i thought summed it all up
perfectly
joseph would you have wanted a man to
talk to
your daughter that way so just so we're
clear
when you watch that you're like that's
cool i would never mind anyone talking
to my daughter like that
and yes if if like my daughter did
something like that
i would hope someone would call her out
he would
what did you guys think of joseph's
appearance
i was blown away everybody truly i could
not believe that joseph completely stood
by
everything he'd said and done on the
show no i have no regrets and no
apologies no qualms nothing
after all that is joseph now the worst
villain
in bachelorette history because he had
no apology
whatsoever i'm not going to apologize to
claire
let me know in the comments below
the men tell all is often kind of a
paradise audition i'm predicting for him
no tasha come on out and join us oh and
then tasha comes in and she is looking
beautiful and we have some gorgeous
conversations with blake
it just like hit me that i just sent
like an amazing man home
with riley you allowed me you know to be
vulnerable and overcome you know my
fears and that's pretty much it to be
honest the bennett did have a green
juice for everyone
and for my little baby herb baby noah
we've got a little baby sippy cup got
two-handed or one-handed two hands
probably
thank you fellas what did you think of
this toned down tell-all did you miss
having more guys there
more screaming more people in the hot
seat let me know in the comments below
you know taste is actually gonna be my
family now this is a real thing
everybody come on down to the la quinta
we can't go to your hometown even though
it's called hometowns because of the
current global pandemic and
the way that we have the test oh my god
send quarantine everybody in order to
film this show we cannot visit you where
you are
giving this pandemic obviously we can't
do that we need you to come here so
everybody's been at
the lakita oh but what i didn't know
is that the guys didn't know which of
their family members
had been quarantining there so we have
moved all of the hometowns
here on property were you blown away by
this i really was
of course at this point we have brendan
ben
zach and ivan and chris harrison comes
in
and shares with them which ones of their
loved ones are
on the property you guys want to hear
who's showing up for you
i'm sorry and oh my gosh you guys
we have been nothing but emotional and
the hits just keep on coming
i teared up when they learned who was
there
i don't know if i can handle it your mom
your dad
and your brother matt are here love
those people very much
did you let me know in the comments
below and brendan is going
first your brother daniel his wife
christy
and your niece aaliyah okay they're all
here wow
and we are still peeling back the layers
we find out that brendan lost his father
and so his brother is the father figure
in his life and his brother is here
my older brother is uh the closest thing
i had to a father
you know after my father passed and he's
just been
the most important person in my life
these men are crying
they're hugging grown men cry we raise a
glass to men who are unafraid to show
that they laugh
so brandon's little niece is also here
and he was just really breaking my heart
in the best way he said he wanted to
have kids young
and that that didn't work out for him
even at an early age
i wanted to have kids of my own and it
obviously didn't work out that way for
me
what i love about brendan is that even
in something sad
he seems like somebody finds the
positive nice to meet you
so tasia meets brennan's brother and
they talk about tasha and brendan both
having gone through divorces
you guys both going through a difficult
divorce a lot of people would
let that negatively affect them for the
next five to ten years
and brendan says he only wants to
propose once more in his life
i don't want to do this a second time
yeah yeah and and it failed
a second time yeah and tasia says it's
and i quote
pretty much game over
like it was like game over in the sense
you know like i
truly feel like brennan could be my
husband what
i need a snack i need a snack because i
need some
we should always have chocolate on your
charcuterie by the way a little
chocolate
chocolate covered blueberry very good
with a red wine
and i have two but you know this season
hasn't just been an emotional roller
coaster as we often say
i would call it an emotional fighter jet
we are doing tricks and loop-de-loops in
the sky we are turning ourselves upside
down and all around
because now we got to go to zach
yeah by the way the guys are supposed to
be kind of showing tasha
what their life at home would be like
we're gonna do some new york
things and have some fun and zach's from
new york so he shows her how to
hail a taxi it's gotta be like a little
bit more like tuxed
taxi right here you're joking no yeah
like that
and was anyone else i'm just gonna throw
it out was anyone else
who was another person perhaps possibly
attracted to the way zach hailed a taxi
[Applause]
yeah i don't know if it was because he
was so confident and just doing his
thing or what but
the way he hailed a taxi
was kind of sexy what did you think let
me know in the comments below
by the way this was big to learn i've
wondered this about tasha and zach she's
such an orange county california girl
but zach says that tasha told him she
wants to move to new york
what tasha mentioned in our first
conversation
when i said i live in new york that she
was actually thinking about moving there
that's a big deal the long distance
thing is often a problem for a bachelor
couple
we're gonna get in yeah okay oh but
forget new york now they are in the
fountain at the laquinta and
oh again surprisingly sexy making out
with all our clothes on in the fountain
doing a little straddling i'm into it
but from sexy straddling
to meeting mom come on don't
yes now zach's family is here and they
become the
reality check in the reality tv show you
know
there's always one family who doesn't
seem to really get the whole bachelor
thing
and zach's brother and dad are kind of
like tasha how can you have feelings for
other guys
you try to make a decision amongst four
guys
i don't know that i could be one of
those four guys to be honest with you
this isn't really for us i'm skeptical
about
you know how how it's going to turn out
and tasia's having to say without saying
we're on a tv show i guess it never
really feels good to talk about another
relationship no it doesn't but
but also it's just the reality of the
situation it is reality
which i sort of love i would not be
sitting here
i would not be alive if it wasn't for
your strength
oh but then zach has this beautiful
moment with his mom where he thanks her
for being so strong for him and tells
her that
i was a little confused by this but i
guess that he had lied to her and said
he didn't want to get married and have
kids
but tasha's made him realize he does
well i told the lie that i didn't want
kids and i wanted to just be an uncle
but what i've realized i think is
important for you to hear is that
i do want a family what did you think of
that confession
let me know in the comments below oh
there's so much to discuss
how are you guys the snacks how's your
shirt kuttery going how's your wine
going let me know in the comments below
oh and tasha says she could see herself
marrying zach
i could really see myself marrying him
at the end of this to be honest
but we're moving we're grooving we're
flying through the sky time for i
then we are meeting his parents and
tasha is so
nervous how are you feeling i'm nervous
are you yes
was it just me or did tasha seem more
nervous to meet ivan's family than any
other
and maybe we know why vin i vin's dad is
older and
he is wiser he
dropped some marital knowledge
on us all i got married at the age
24 my bride was 20.
in retrospect we were both too young
i took my time before i got married
again
oh but as much as i loved ivan's parents
ivan kept saying that
you know he really wanted his brother to
be there don't drink for every time he
sat in this heartbreaking way you know i
was really hoping my niece kelani
yeah and my brother um can make it
because they're like my brother like
he's the most influential person in my
life
i just wish my brother was able to make
it it would have meant the world for me
um for my brother to be here for sure
and then
and then and then
this show is trying to annihilate
our amygdalas the amygdala is allegedly
of the emotional
core of our brains i did look that up
his brother appears
[Applause]
and cue the tears cue the tears
to the tears the biggest surprise of the
night was my brother was here
i was crying were you crying i was
crying
and so much knowledge from this family
ivan's brother
said something that will stick with me
you guys he said
loyalty is an action word
loyalty that's an action word
and ivan will demonstrate that if given
the chance
he will demonstrate that antagia says
she wants to be a part of this family
and i do too
they made me feel really special and
included like that's a family i want to
be a part of
by the way i love that tasha and ivan's
mom were kind of like unintentionally
matching
also let's just raise our glasses to
tasha's fashions
this episode don't drink for every time
she looked great
[Applause]
so which outfit was your favorite let me
know in the comments below
now ivan did say he isn't sure if he's
ready to propose
but am i ready to propose to her no i'm
not but he also says he is
falling in love with tasha frankly um i
really am
falling in love with t-shit and i
couldn't remember you guys tell me and i
haven't said this to tasha before
i'm i'm like trying to take inventory of
all the relationships at this point
because i'm really having a tough time
deciphering
which one is the strongest are you
we're only one week from the finale who
do you think tasha ends up with if
anyone
let me know in the comments below
cue the tears
[Music]
oh but we got one more and it's gonna
take
us to the floor it's been
so we're with ben and tasia says when he
looks at her
it's like he's looking into her soul
when ben looks at me it's like he's
looking into my soul
how do you do that
am i looking into your soul
who could look into a person's soul
voldemort is the first person who comes
to my mind
i've ever shown you guys my voldemort
impression this is like very
specifically when he's not in a full
body yet he's like probably on the back
of coral's head
harry potter harry
potter harry potter
harry potter i'm sorry
it's niche okay
[Applause]
what do you think of my voldemort
impression let me know in the comments
below okay so ben is looking into
tasha's soul and we are looking at some
excellent
pool makeouts cheers to more sexy
aesthetics
now ben said his parents couldn't be
there because of the pandemic and his
dad is a doctor but his sister who he is
very close with is present and
one of his very best friends who is
did anyone recognize this is a famous
face but they didn't really acknowledge
it
chef antonia of top chef
maybe powder and sprinkle exactly yes
top chef on bravo you guys
you guys you guys as much as i love the
bachelor and the bachelorette of course
i also watch
other reality tv i love 90 day fiance
hey
and i am a big bravo girl and is this
the bravo bachelor crossover
that i've been waiting for
kind of well chef antonia
did a little cooking because she made
ben realize
that he loves tasha
you love her i don't know you love her
it's not even a question magic in the
kitchen
by the way if you're confused ben lives
in la and chef antonia has like three
restaurants here so i think you must
just know her from living in l.a
i've gone to eat in her spots bachelor
bravo crossover
and now back to our show it's the rose
ceremony oh and this is a big one
this is for the fantasy sweets and
brandon is in his
trademark a turtleneck and i definitely
remember him from
that and zack gets a rose and ivan gets
a rose
and it comes down to brandon and
ben this is the final rose tonight i did
not see this coming
did you i'm in love with her and
i should have told her and we say
goodbye
to ben brendan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ben i'm sorry take a moment say your
goodbyes
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know how to feel i like brendan
but i'd also grown so attached to ben
were you shocked let me know in the
comments
below i mean what
is happening i just did not understand
the why and tasia takes ben out to say
goodbye
and her explanation is that their pages
aren't aligned i don't know if our
our pages are necessarily aligned at
this time there are no tears here
even though tasha just cried over blake
and
riley sorry ben i was so
confused did you understand why she sent
ben home
and ben was also emotionally kind of
shutting down
he said he was heartbroken but he'd be
all right
like i'm heartbroken but i'll be all
right and it was kind of a heartbreaking
thing to hear tasha was also upset with
ben for
not showing emotion it was extremely
disappointing
there was no emotion at all but i gotta
say i was thinking tasha girl
you just dumped him and you're mad at
him for not being
more upset why didn't you show a little
emotion
oh but now ben has left and tasha is
crying it's like they both went their
separate ways
and wish they'd said things to each
other because ben is in the limo saying
maybe she didn't think i loved her maybe
i effing
blew it maybe she loved me and she
thought i didn't love her back
[Music]
and then if that's the case i blew it
it's been four hours of tv i think they
both blew it at the end here
i am baffled
but we've got to keep going we're so
close to the finish
it's the trailer for the finale
yes everybody next week we have got
another one
two part two night finale monday night
and tuesday night and our emotional
fighter jet is still speeding through
the air
so many tears never want to experience
that heartache that i experienced my
last mirage
and a man who gives me fear tasha's dad
i don't want you to be making the
biggest mistake of your life
yes we will be here for it all and my
prediction babes is that given how
invested these guys are this is gonna be
a tear bath yeah i just invented that
it's a bloodbath but it's made of tears
oh my god
oh what's not to love and i love you all
so much
thank you for watching if you want to
connect with me more i am available on
twitter
instagram tick tock and cameo if you
want a personal message from me head to
their website i am at laurenzema
and very importantly you guys the finale
we always do it live and we're gonna do
it again monday night we are going
live right after the episode right here
on roses and rose
we will be live taking your comments and
questions
talking about what happened and tuesday
night we're doing it too
two nights of back-to-back live episodes
don't miss it i love you guys so much
thanks for watching and i'll see you
live for two nights next week bye
you know
oh it's been a lot
[Music]
um
you